lots of people say we should get America
working again by buying American
products and there's really no excuse
not to buy American because we all know
the difference between what's American
and what's foreign apple pie
Americans kidney pie foreign football
American football foreign bikini girls
American bikini dudes definitely formed
so it's fitting that Spike TV's the two
bandits would smash this orange caused
by American they say and who wants to
argue with bikini beige not President
Obama the time for talk is over the time
for action is now there's plenty of
action in his 800 billion dollar
stimulus package which includes a buy
American provision designed to get
Americans back to work later on he gave
the Queen of England an iPod thus
continuing his patriotic streak by
giving huge publicity to that beloved
doodad that's designed in California and
sprung from the brain of a guy named
Steve is there a more American name than
Steve is there a more American product
than the iPod it's not an American
product
what do you mean the iPod is not
American almost all the components
inside of that product are made and
assembled in foreign countries he's
professor Donald Boudreaux an economist
at George Mason University he points to
this study which took the iPod apart and
figured out where each of the parts
comes from the screen comes from Japan
the batteries from Chile the CPU design
well that was licensed from a British
company and that's just the beginning
all in all the iPods 451 parts come from
dozens of nations the iPod itself is
assembled in a foreign country and not
just any foreign country China
pothinus China is made in China
something's going on with China seems
like just about everyone
Bish's of China so why is the president
passing off the commie pod as an
all-american product instead of buying
iPod maybe patriotic Americans should be
smashing them we hired our own bikini
fandoms they teach people the truth
about the event maybe the Edit
Steelworkers you you would like to hire
these patriotic ladies money in words
they're providing jobs in their
countries even chance the United
Steelworkers union is one of the biggest
by American backers actually we are lots
of the federal stimulus money is going
towards fixing roads bridges on the one
with some exceptions materials like
steel that are used for road work must
be made in the USA and it's not just
federal law so I proudly present this to
the working people of West Virginia
represented by the labor of West
Virginia at this rally the governor of
West Virginia presented union leaders
with a by American proclamation this
sort of thing is happening all across
the nation the United Steelworkers union
recently organized a by American bus
tour that hit 34 cities and culminated
with a Washington DC event where
business owners and activists learned
how to lobby for more protectionist laws
if you use America money you buy
American goods if you want to sell it
here build it here and what about those
who don't buy American obviously they're
uneducated and they need people even
though we are the most productive and
most efficient workers in the world we
put our goods as kind of junk it's more
exotic to have a Volvo rather than a
ship
this is out but it's more patriotic to
have a Chevy because if you're an
American it starts here if you have
patriotism you look at by an American
after looking at those cute American
kids and with the US automakers hurting
so badly maybe we should buy American
Chevy America's bridge supports
America's best you could even use your
Chevy to smash some of those traitorous
mp3 players then again let's not take
that job from these American ladies
maybe there should be a by American law
for iPod who was that whoever it was
he's right the iPod is American sorta
because the the idea of the human
creativity that makes the iPod reality
that did originate in America yes plenty
of foreigners have jobs thanks to the
iPod and so do fourteen thousand
Americans whose duties include designing
and marketing the little buggers and so
is it American or not it's very
difficult to tell
actually well maybe the iPod is just a
tricky exception good thing most other
purchases are straightforward like
buying the most patriotic ride available
the Jeep Patriot
that's gotta help America that's
nonsense first of all the Jeep Patriot
despite its name and despite its label
is actually probably less American than
some Toyota products turns out that the
Patriots rival the Toyota Sequoia is
made up of eighty percent American parts
making it more American than the Patriot
which is only 66 percent American so
what's a patriotic bikini bandit to do
smash a patriot and how can we consumers
know we're buying an American car I
think it'd be almost impossible are you
willing to find out where each of your
cars parts comes from and these days
so-called foreign cars are often built
in America by Americans and remember
that foreign autumn
or Volvo gets more exotic to have rather
than a shitty well actually Volvo is
owned by a company called Ford the
categories american-made foreign-made
are really not very useful you're going
to become a force of working families
auditors to make sure the buy American
provisions are being fulfilled that may
be tough remember that American steel
that's being bought with stimulus dough
nations like Austria the Ukraine in
South Africa all have a hand in making
American steel
welcome to the iPod economy where just
about everything is made everywhere it's
literally impossible at least in any
practical sense to buy American
and yet the buy American idea is so
popular we come together today to insist
that taxpayer money our money our money
it's fair to create jobs here in West
Virginia and in America they look at
Americans buying things for foreigners
and what they see them as all the
Americans that are not buying things
from other Americans and that's putting
some Americans out of work how terrible
but they don't look at the other half of
what's going on here's what's going on
let's say you want to buy a box of
throwing stars you use $100 bill to buy
it from a Chinese company the hundred
dollar bill goes into the company's
Chinese bank account but the only reason
the bank accepts the hundred dollar bill
is because it knows someone else will
want it one day a Chinese woman goes to
the bank and exchanges Chinese currency
for US dollars
there's your hundred dollar bill again
the woman travels to America where she
could spend that money on all sorts of
things meals software even an iPod and
when foreigners spend those dollars in
America they employ Americans no less
than when Americans spend those dollars
you'd think that'd be enough for us to
put down our sledgehammers and embrace
global trade that's what these patriotic
ladies did when they learn the whole
story do you think it'd be smashing
iPods in the future
actually a good thing but plenty of
folks are still mad the products like
the iPod aren't built entirely
unfortunately some corporation decided
it was cheaper to manufacture in another
country and ship back and to me it was
on Patriot and that needs to end I
disagree me first of all the thing
that's most distinctively American is
freedom that free trade stuff that's a
bunch of crap who insists that you
should not be free Americans should not
be free to buy goods from foreigners
that's very entire America but what if
we passed a new law saying that iPods
had to be built entirely in there well
that would likely make them so expensive
that only people like presidents and
queens could afford them and what would
that do to the 14,000 Americans whose
jobs depend on the iPod for reason TV
I'm Nicolas